[Music]
hi I'm Hannah your friendly neighborhood
one mom and if you're anything like me
you believe that a glass of wine at 8
p.m. makes you a better mom so pour
yourself a glass and let's talk tonight
we're drinking Rose a because I'm always
drinking Rosie what else am I gonna
drink Rose a all day a topic that runs
rampant in the comments of all of these
videos is discipline how do I discipline
kids how do I deal with difficult
children so tonight's topic the best way
to discipline kids and I know because I
am a certified mom I've been certified
by the board of certifiers of moms first
context whenever I'm about to punish my
children I have to make the decision
are they misbehaving or are they just
acting their age my oldest son is 4 he
likes to do stuff himself he likes to
get his own glasses of water that's his
new thing so he gets on his little
stepstool and gets water out of the
filtered spout next to her sink but he
always pulls his water cup up to the
very top of the brim and then he spilled
it everywhere
they're just puddles of water all over
the house whenever he tries to get his
own water but I'm not gonna punish him
for that because he's 4 and that's
normal the other hand if he thinks I'm
not looking he'll give his younger
brother a big shove kids need to learn
that we see everything so I know that
that's happening I see it and he will
get in trouble for that because spilling
water just being a kid pushing your
brother just being a jerk sometimes
bumping music outside I was like a bunch
of crazy teens in my neighborhood it's
normal they're gonna blast their music
to a douchey level next what I never use
the one-two-three method I've done it
several times and I'll get all the way
to three but I realized that I haven't
thought it out to even figure out what's
gonna happen when I get to three so when
I do it's just like okay it totally
loses its effectiveness if there's no
follow-through on what's gonna happen so
instead I bought this shirt and it
sprays alight that I read and was just
like this really speaks to me and it
says I say what not because I didn't
hear you
but because I'm giving you a chance to
change what you just said it's in very
small letters and so I say that to every
crappy thing my kid says they'll be like
oh you're the meanest move ever when I
don't give him three cookies instead of
two and I'll turn around and be like
what and he's like oh no I'm just
getting these two cookies are great give
them a chance to correct themselves
before they get punished which i think
is very important my hand is making it
warm I have to hold on to the stem I've
seen that in the comments people were
like hold the stab and the wine won't
get warm thank you next lead by example
I always try to act in the way that I
expect my children to act I want them to
use manners so I always use manners when
I'm interacting with them if I ask them
to do something I'll say please if they
do it are say thank you I see a lot of
parents who don't do that and they just
kind of bark orders at their kids and
expect them to use manners and be polite
and I don't think that's right if I'm
talking to my husband I'll say hi how
was your day how are you doing what's
going on and so when I come home from
work and I see my four year old the
first thing he asks me is how was your
day mom and it's just the most
heartwarming thing simply before your
oldest asking me and cares enough but
it's because he sees it in the way that
his parents behave with other people if
on top of that he came up to me with a
glass of wine and said hey mom how was
your day
that would just see you I'm just kidding
I'm not gonna teach my kid to pour one
for me next offer choices I'll offer him
choices of two things he doesn't like
and therefore he will feel like he's in
control but still ends up doing both
things that he doesn't like do you want
to brush your teeth first or take a bath
do you want to eat this carrot first or
this broccoli first he gets to pick you
pick whatever piece of crap you want
this is some low-key manipulation that I
like to do and I'm pretty sure that this
is a tactic they use in the FBI or
something like that when they're
interrogating people but it works just
as well for kids and sometimes there are
the rare instances when the child will
say something like me there and I want
to do either one
I don't want to take baths I don't want
to rush my teeth I don't want to eat
carrots I don't want any properly and
that's when you pull out the nut it all
fits together in this intricate web of
discipline no burps this episode next go
easy on yourself yeah I want my kids to
be disciplined properly but in a
situation where I'm about to lose my
[ __ ] I thought I'd give up I got to
throw in the towel raise the white flag
whatever as a parent you're not gonna
win every battle and that's fine
nobody's perfect no kid is perfect no
parent is perfect no discipline is
perfect which leads us to our very final
and ultimate rule when it comes to
disciplining kids don't take unsolicited
advice from complete strangers there are
so many parents who are willing to just
like bark their discipline tactics as
truth and that's not true because each
child is different every parent is
different every relationship is
different everything is different as far
as what works and if you're about to
share this video with the caption oh she
doesn't know anything that discipline it
doesn't work joke's on you because I
really don't what do I know I don't know
your kids I don't know you I don't know
anything this is the discipline method
that works for me
it might not work for you it might work
for somebody else bottom line with
discipline with what you have is working
keep doing it unless you're spanking
your kids because that [ __ ] is really
weird just save that for the vendor I'm
sorry I yelled at you I really do love
you that's all I got for today
I'm hammy your friendly neighborhood
wine mom and if there's a method of
discipline that particularly works for
you whether you're a babysitter or nanny
or a parent or whatever you are leave it
in the comments but be nice because if
you're not nice we can't be best friends
see what I did there with my discipline
method if you do this and you can't have
this all right so I'm probably going to
finish this little what's left of Rosie
and go up a dance party with my husband
because
that's what cool parents do til next
time
[Music]
easier without a glass I don't like
watching wine glasses
[Music]